hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream coming to you from
dark horse headquarters here in
portlandish
something
in any case it is live stream number is
it 120. it's 120 120. and you i feel
like we have not mentioned this for a
while you are brett weinstein
and i am heather hines i am dr brett
weinstein you are dr heather heing and
this may become relevant in this year
podcast as uh as we are biologists most
of you know that doctors of philosophy
which many phds do not actually take
seriously nor do their departments in
fact i once had a
historian i believe it was laugh at me
when i suggested that actually the phd
that scientists that academic scientists
earn
is precisely because one ought to be
schooled in the philosophy of science
and she thought that was hilarious
because so patently untrue and i have to
say largely it is untrue but not
not in our case and not in any other
scientist's case you had ought to be
schooled in the philosophy lest you get
schooled by the philosophy that's what
happens if you don't understand the
philosophy of science is that right it
is i mean we've seen this again and
again all sorts of people walking around
with phds who skipped the philosophy of
science and then turn out to say absurd
foolish things and have no idea that's
what they're doing you know we're going
to talk about all sorts of women stuff
today but uh afterwards we both have one
or two other things we want to talk
about i actually don't know what's on
your list
but on my list is uh sharing an op-ed
that was just published in the bmj the
british medical journal uh and just a
paragraph out of which in which they
invoke carl popper uh one of our
favorite not
not infallible but one of our favorite
philosophers of science from the mid
20th century
so we're going to we're going to go back
a little back circle on there initially
a skeptic of of uh
darwinian adaptation indeed or at least
a skeptic that it could be rigorously
studied who then later came around
which many people do not realize because
in his early writings that skepticism is
uh front and center but
you know who else was early on a skeptic
of what would become uh known as
darwinian selection was darwin
quite right himself
so uh so you know people people uh as
evidence comes in and as they have other
experiences in the world change their
minds yep which we call flip-flopping
is it only if we're fish
politicians
flopping
yeah
um
all right so
announcements announcements before we
get into all that womanly stuff and
philosophy of science and various other
things that you want to be talking about
we will at the end of this intro section
be bringing you three ads as has become
our want we are as ever grateful to our
ad sponsors uh which this week are
blinkist
sorry md hearing aid and ned so we'll
get to that in a couple of minutes
we continue to get um great feedback and
translation rights are selling um i
don't know if translation rights could
sell like hotcakes because it's sort of
a slower rate than that but two um our
balcony gathers guide to the 21st
century and if you are
interested in how biologists come to
understand things like
sex
and uh and what it makes what it takes
to be a woman for instance uh i i
recommend our book i do not have what it
takes no you don't no no and you never
will
and uh
yes we do and i am grateful for that
um
i'm grateful that we know that and also
that you don't have what it takes
because you know if you did
uh our producer wouldn't exist neither
would his younger brother in the next
room over that's right we would not be
his producers as we are
that he would not be our producer
as he is right
this is getting confusing quickly isn't
it uh that's what happens when you start
talking about what it is that makes a
woman
no
okay uh we are we're streaming live on
both youtube and odyssey
and uh the chat is live on odyssey if
you want to join it there excuse me
and shortly after uh shortly after the
stream is over uh we will of course be
doing our q a uh you can ask questions
at www.darkhorsesubmissions.com
for the q a uh and actually both the
main uh both the this main episode and
the q a will go out on spotify that
started happening and um people seem to
be liking that so there was there was
there were requests so spotify has both
the video and the audio
um tomorrow on my patreon is our monthly
private q a which we have a ton of fun
with it's small enough that we actually
do engage with the chat and do engage
with people um who are there at the time
and then we leave it up for uh for
patrons uh so you can uh join with the
questions have already been asked we
will go through those i'll go through
those tonight and prioritize them and
then we'll go through them but also veer
off in various directions for our two
hour q a tomorrow at 11. questions have
been asked but they are maturing and
then we will get to them tomorrow they
are yes i've uncorked them and they are
breathing as we speak yes
bye before we come
i swear we're sober um i mean it's early
why wouldn't we be of course we are
we're not we're not the sort of people
who wouldn't be at this point um or have
we ever been
no
um
before we come back to you next week
with episode 121 you will have
one of your two patreon conversations of
of the month uh the saturday one being
the uh coalition of the reasonable okay
and it is full of very
reasonable awesome people excellent
excellent
and let's see what else various other
things we have the same stuff that we've
had for a while but there's a diversity
of it at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org get your
t-shirts and your
blankets and your bags and such there
uh i posted this week as i do every week
on naturalselections.substance.com
probably this upcoming week i haven't
written it yet but it's going to be
something
related to the vein of what it takes to
be a woman uh
because that does seem to be one of the
things that is grabbing a lot of
people's attention and strangely
confusing to people who until yesterday
knew this because it was obvious yeah
um and before we get into the ads we
wanted to introduce you guys to a new
venture called the digital public square
which i have a little script for but uh
you wanted to specifically introduce
yeah i wanted to say that a number of us
have noticed the encroachment of tyranny
in various places it has been widely
discussed on
social media
interesting stuff happened this week
actually
tucker carlson and the babylon b were
both suspended on twitter
um
really yeah it's pretty i heard about
the babylon b they took they took tucker
carlson and the babylon b at the same
time they realized that one of those is
a parody account and one of them's not
right no parody parody's wrong sarcasm i
don't even know what one of them is a
parody irony and the other one is
somebody who is hardly going to be
silenced by
suspending him on twitter
um so anyway yeah it's fascinating stuff
and they were suspended for
effectively i've forgotten the term that
twitter uses but basically means
spiritedness
uh were they not being uh
hateful
they weren't being collegial maybe right
which raises a certain question which
we've heard that an academic company do
we really want an entity like twitter
being the arbiter of when content is
hateful right i certainly don't i think
that sounds incredibly dangerous but
twitter apparently does think that's the
appropriate role for it so anyway
people have noticed that this is not a
stable place for anybody with an opinion
that is uh
contrary to the mainstream even when the
mainstream's opinion is generated out of
bullying and it's not even the
mainstream opinion it's just
masquerading as the mainstream opinion
so
we have teamed up with folks over the
course of years trying to figure out
what the way out and the recent
spasm of tyranny surrounding
all things covet and other
uh team blue phenomenon has uh
lit a fire under several of our uh
friends and they are hard at work on a
project which heather is about
to describe yeah uh so we will link to
um
simonsdap.com where you can learn more
in the show notes um but
in the meantime we um we have this
little bit of introduction heterodox
thinkers have caused for concern about
censorship and manipulation on the
social web
a handful of centralized platforms have
cornered what should have been the
digital public square and now have
outsized influence over our public
conversation exactly as brett was just
talking about decentralized alternatives
offer freedom from this influence but
full participation tends to require more
digital elbow grease than most people
have patience for you know there are
some solutions but it requires really
paying active attention to your to your
tech life and um by and large people
want to be able to forget that to
background it
the same zdap project is bringing a
plug-and-play experience to the
decentralized web just like roku adapted
internet streaming to tvs built around
cable providers samsdap is adapting the
decentralized web to phones and tablets
built around central servers the samsdap
team knows that the decentralized web is
larger than they can survey alone which
is why they've asked us to reach out to
our audience for recommendations
of projects that are aligned with the
vision of creating the digital public
square that we all deserve if you're
already sold and bursting with
suggestions visit
suggestions.samisdap that's
s-a-m-i-z-d-a-p-p
dot com
suggestions.samisdapp.com to tell them
what you know
if you're interested in the concept and
want to learn more visit samusdap.com
um and read the manifesto and if you
have a better name for the project email
stop being a nerd at sammystab.com
that's included last minute i believe um
anything more you want to say about um i
mean i think so so um
it actually doesn't look like the sub
stack link but um at least they've also
um produced the manifesto i guess on on
the substitute i believe that link does
take you it's gonna take you there to
the rationale um same
uh is a play on samisdat and app yeah um
so anyway better name is in order but
some is done it's very much the right
kind of i like it and so i was kind of
pronouncing it sam's dap um to make it
clear that it's
the
uh well in any case um the the dissident
literature uh from uh behind the iron
curtain is the uh
the concept this is the trope um so in
any case uh
very interested to see how this project
develops very excited for it and uh it's
not a moment too soon
we are in danger indeed
all right um so now uh without further
ado hold on a couple more uh
announcements oh okay
one several of you wrote in with what i
took to be a brilliant suggestion that i
moved my microphone so that when i talk
to heather which is something i have
enjoyed doing for decades uh that it
does not cause my audio to drop out so
you will note yeah mine is usually but
mine mine has been readjusted in my
absence i guess
um don't know can't say what happened i
don't think it was you i think it was
the cats um second thing i don't want to
forget to mention that akira the dawn
you all know who akira the dawn is akira
the dawn has taken
uh my dr seuss poem and has turned it
into i don't know what to call it is it
a song i guess it's a song but anyway
it's a musical
circus act he's turned it into a thing
the poem was already sort of a circus
act
but you all will remember when we were
the powers that be were trying to
convince us that there was something
wrong with dr seuss and therefore
something wrong with those of us who
still liked the guy um and anyway i
delivered a poem right here on darkhorse
and the kiera the dawn has done things
with it so check that out we will put a
link in the description and um
uh you can all uh
enjoy
i probably accurate needs a name for the
genre that he seems to be inventing
um let's see was there another
announcement
maybe that's it all right
um all right
as i mentioned we have three ad sponsors
this week
and we were grateful to all of them uh
blinkist is our first which we uh came
to you for the first time with last week
blinkist is a company founded on the
idea that almost none of us have the
time to read everything we'd like to
read
yet we lose countless hours to
activities that bring us little joy such
as commuting chores and staring at our
phones blinkist encapsulates books into
their most concentrated forms and allows
users to take away valuable ideas by
investing time that they might otherwise
have lost blink is just 10 years old
this year and their theme is 22 ideas
for 2022.
there are lots of books that i want to
read blinkist provides a way to learn
and clear the list to some degree what
books is blink is perfect for which ones
don't i need to need or want to know any
more about and which weren't an actual
read
i use blankets for books i'm interested
in because i know the authors and
respect them and i'm curious to see what
else they've done for instance daniel
pink's drive
which is about motivation specifically
what he calls motivation 3.0
in this book he um according to the
blinkist of it talks about relying on
intrinsic rather than extrinsic
motivation and i found reinforcement of
reading the blinkists blinks i think of
conclusions i had come to teaching
college for so many years
i also use blinkist for books i've heard
about i want to know a little more but
i'm unlikely to read in full such as
atomic habits by james clear
and i think that kind of very
straightforward book is is really
perfect for a blankest approach and i
also use it as a kind of library i have
on my nightstand for instance debt by
david graber but it's very long and i
haven't gotten fire far into it looking
up debt on blinkist i find other books
on similar topics that are intriguing
much like browsing the stacks of a
library this process of discovery can be
some of the most wonderful aspects of
looking through blinkist finding things
you didn't know you were looking for
didn't know existed and quickly learning
something new
blinkist is abundant and excellent
content to help you become more
empowered inspired and motivated in 2022
and right now blinkist has a special
offer just for our audience go to
blinkist.com darkhorse to start your
free seven-day trial and get 25 off a
blinkist premium membership that's
blinkist b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t
blinkist dot com slash dark horse for 25
off in a seven day free trial once more
blinkist.com
darkhorse
and our second sponsor
uh for this week is md hearing aid
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
but largely hearing loss is invisible to
those of us without it
md hearing aid was founded by an ent
surgeon who saw how many of his patients
needed hearing aids but couldn't afford
them he made it his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone can
afford he recognized that about 95 of
people who need a hearing aid only
require a few settings so he removed
some components that are not needed by
most people and cut out the middleman
now md hearing aid makes a rechargeable
hearing aid that is fda registered and
costs a small fraction of what typical
hearing aids cost
they aim to fit so well that no one will
know you're wearing them the
rechargeable batteries last about 30
hours their volt plus
model is water resistant and up to three
feet of water and you don't need a
prescription to get one you buy it
directly from the source where
audiologists and licensed hearing
specialists are available seven days a
week
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids as we've
mentioned many times before we only take
sponsors for products that we can
directly assess and will use ourselves
or in a few very rare cases
there are very few very rare exceptions
to that and this is one of them
so we asked a friend who relies on her
hearing aids
to try these out and this is what she
said with my particular type of hearing
loss a deep male voice in a noisy room
is the hardest situation for me to hear
and understand speech i wore the md
hearing aid to have a conversation with
a deep voice man in a room with a lot of
white noise the md hearing aid passed
the test as my conversation partner's
voice was clear and understandable at a
price point of under a thousand dollars
i was amazed at how effective they are
so md hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers plus they offer a 45-day
risk-free trial with a hundred percent
money-back guarantee so get clinical no
get clinic level care for 80 less with
md hearing aid go to md hearing aid.com
and use promo code darkhorse to get
their buy one get one 299
dollars and 99 cents each when you buy a
pair deal plus they are adding a free
extra charging case 100 value just for
listeners of darkhorse so head to md
earring
md hearing aid that's m d h e a r ing
aid dot com and use our promo code
darkhorse or you can even call them at
1-833-772-1392
awesome
our final sponsor this week is ned a cbd
company that stands out in a highly
saturated someone say super saturated
cbd market
ned was started by two friends who
discovered that their hyper modern lives
were leaving them feeling empty
bewildered and disconnected something
about this way of life they say on their
website just wasn't working so they
started ned
you can buy ned products in nearly no
you can buy cbd products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but ned's
blends stand out their sleep blend has
really impressed us for instance
their new sleep formulation blends cbn a
powerful cannabinoid that promotes sleep
with 750 milligrams of usda certified
organic cbd from the purest single
source hemp flour extract and organic
wild crafted botanicals traditionally
used for sleep
many of the cbd companies out there
source their hemp from industrial farms
in china just like with low quality
alcohol however low quality cbd can have
undesired effects
ned is usda certified organic all of
ned's full spectrum hemp oil is
extracted from usda certified organic
hemp plants grown by an independent
farmer named jonathan in payonea
colorado also ned shares third-party lab
reports and information about who forms
their products and their extraction
process on their site
these products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they are chock
full of premium cbd and full of spectrum
spectrum active cannabinoids terpenes
flavonoids and trichomes
ned's full spectrum hemp oil nourishes
the body's endocannabinoid system to
offer functional support for stress
sleep inflammation and balance it's
ned's birthday month no ned it's ned's
birth month
uh if you like
that was their language i know but i'm
you know no no i'm i'm just saying that
well gently controlling them
if you'd like to give their new and
improved sleep blend a try dark horse
listeners get 21
off with the code darkhorse for the
month of march only
it's their best offer of the year visit
helloned.com slash dark horse to get
access that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d dot com slash darkhorse
to get 21 off
thank you ned for sponsoring the show
and offering our listeners a natural
remedy for some of life's most common
health issues
excellent
that
is our sponsors for the week
um
so we're going to talk a little bit
about um
about womanness
about womanness because
um
katanji brown jackson who is biden's uh
pick uh to uh to be the next member of
the supreme court united states um who
was you know well qualified for the job
she is she has a an incredible i don't
know if they call it a cv in legal
circles but an incredible
um
background um yeah i don't think it's a
cb i think resume but yeah okay
um
but uh somewhat famously uh she was
asked in the hearings this week
uh if she could
after a little bit of back and forth if
she could define what a woman is and she
said uh no in this context she could not
define what a woman is because quote i'm
not a biologist
well um
lucky for all you we are biologists and
we can define what a woman is but i
should say it doesn't take a biologist
to define what a woman is and uh before
you interrupt yeah all right i wanna i
wanna just say that i was going to seed
the floor because of course what it is
to be a woman is to be sort of
deferential and to always let the man
take the lead and to um you know
probably go clean some stuff up or maybe
make a cake or something
that is
what it is to be a woman so well
not an expert exactly though i'm gonna
explain it because that's what it is to
be a man but you're a biologist which is
the expert that we've been called on to
seek and we are both biologists and yet
clearly your madness should trump my
womanness in answering the question on
account of
what now
well
all right let me start my interruption
and explaining uh discipline i'm going
to explain
i actually think her answer
was perfectly justified
um
it's not that i think she couldn't have
given the obvious answer and that would
have been equally justified but at the
current moment i certainly understand
that
from the perspective of somebody for
whom this is not their
uh their core interest in the world that
being asked the question to define a
term like this you know it's not it's
not
a simple well it is a simple matter but
it's not necessarily obvious that it
would be a simple matter because people
have raised all sorts of complexities
which i will point out are irrelevant to
the definition
so i'm going to interrupt you now
we're going to go back and forth a lot
because there's a lot a lot to say here
but um
i went ahead you know
first what rang in my in my ears uh was
kelly j keane right um the awesome the
awesome uh british feminist
also a woman um who also goes by uh
posey parker we've both been on her show
um
somehow not a biologist and yet she
seems to have a really good grasp of
this um famously says adult human female
adult human
female right it's just not that hard so
i
didn't know if this was her formulation
so i went ahead and looked it up a few
places okay uh i went onto
dictionary.com
adult female person
okay
merriam-webster online also adult female
person and then i pulled out i went for
the big guns in fact i had to wake our
producer up this morning to pull out the
the oed okay so we happen to have a hard
copy of the oed
we actually had two hard copies of the
oed because both of our parents got
these for us when we were children and
at some point we're like
we're in this for the long haul we do
not in fact need two hard copies of the
oxford english dictionary in our home so
we only have the one at this point here
it is and this is of course
the box is falling apart um the second
the second volume this is p through z
plus the supplement and bibliography um
and their definition of woman is um also
just take a look at the at the text here
this is um it ain't it ain't big women
in this book have been belittled along
with everything else along with
everything else um
yeah
and in fact rather than use the handy uh
magnifying glass that they include i
have magnifying glasses built into my
eyes by virtue of um being both myopic
and presbyopic at this point so i'm
going to read their definition of woman
and it goes on for a while but the very
first definition is
an adult female human
being
okay um so wait i want to i want to leap
in and make a point i noticed uh i
barely saw anything on
the internet this week but neil oliver
tweeted something about basically
banking hard copies of books and uh
documentaries and movies and things that
can't be retconned right because the
does that sound retroactive continuity
so part of the problem how is
retroactive how did how i don't i don't
get that as the part of speech there but
okay well
let's just put it to you this way those
who wish to change the definition and
pretend that it was always defined in
some other way have lots of opportunity
on the net they do not have an
opportunity to go back and change some
book that's been collecting dust for
however many decades i was pleased to
find that the two most common
dictionaries online had basically the
same definition that uh the kelly j king
uses and that the oed has been using
right for now
for now for now and we have seen things
like uh the definition of vaccine
changed uh subtly
in recent months and anti-vaxxer things
like this right all these things so
anyway hard copies of books are uh
coming back because they can't be
changed remotely yeah
um so i know you you're going somewhere
you were you were busy explaining stuff
but i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm going to explain um just a little
bit more about this seemingly very
simple definition but you're going to
double x plane yes i am
um
yeah yes i am um so adult human female
right yep there will be those then that
will say okay then you need to define
those three words
fair enough can do
adult
of reproductive age or post reproductive
age in any organism right we talk about
juveniles we talk about adults um and is
the entertainment of reproductive aging
yeah the is you know is the border going
to be somewhat fuzzy are there
differences even with the united states
about what the age of consent is you
know it is reproductive age at the point
of first menses or is it the point of
peak fertility it's not peak fertility
but
the average age of first reproduction in
the species as it turns out for
senescence purposes yeah and given that
we're just marching that earlier because
we're over feeding and over harmonizing
our girls in particular then you know
that's that's changing harmonizing yes
it's not a word but
i just tried it out it doesn't really
work um but adult okay but you know
having attained um you know the i i
think i think probably this is going to
be it you know the average age of
attainment of reproductive capacity in a
species um that does mean that there
will be species where adults of males
and females are going to be different
right it's going to be
some years in some cases where usually
it will be
the females have attained reproductive
capacity before the males
um human
or person because we see both of those
in these very simple three word
definitions of what it takes to be a
woman with what a woman is
uh and you know there's going to be a
lot of ink spilled as to exactly what
this is but the simplest thing i would
say is any living organism in any living
organism in the genus homo is a human
okay you know that's going to exclude a
whole lot of humans and it but you know
in terms of like hmm
are we looking at a woman here like if
if it's if it's a living person if it's
a if it's of a living organism in the
genus homo
that's a person you're looking at
those are pretty simple
female is going to be the one where
people get um
their babies
without getting evicted from the
internet no but if we were across the
pond we would get uh evicted from you
know we'd have to just keep popping
across the pond depending on which of
these we want to say
so um
female
okay adult human female is what a woman
is and that does hinge on what you take
to be the definition of female and
luckily this is a place
uh where biologists know a thing or two
the answer is not complex there's lots
of complexifying things around the edges
which i'm sure we'll get to talking
about
but the fact is that the female of a
species
is
that individual that can or will or has
in the past produce
eggs eggs being gametes the sex cells
that are larger
than the other kind of gamete and tend
to be sessile
they're full of
rich with cytoplasm and they don't tend
to move around much by comparison
uh the male of the species produces
gametes that are little and uh tend to
be mobile or motile in the language of
of sperm so in plants we call them
pollen and in animals we call it sperm
but if you if you have or will or have
in the past
had the capacity to produce little tiny
zippy gametes then you're male
and therefore not a woman and if you
have or
will
or have in the past had the capacity to
or could have had the capacity to absent
some other problem
produce larger cytoplasm rich
immobile largely immobile gametes then
you are female and thus if the other two
things apply if you are both an adult
and a human
you're a woman
so
a number of things one if i wanted to
i could throw all sorts of challenges at
the definitions you just gave please do
then well this would this would be an
exercise in sophistry and i think once
again we have to
um
recognize that the central question here
is one of sophistry right the whole idea
that we are somehow compelled to define
woman a term that everybody knows the
definition of right
and a lot of people are now pretending
they don't
but the point is that we get dragged
into this
is the result of sophistry now i think
it's very important that we actually
respond in this case because um
because of the claim that it's because
i'm not a biologist that i can't answer
the question although again i will
defend that answer i think that was
probably the right thing for her to say
um
because
the problem is a lay person does not
know what to do with the
meaning of the ambiguities right in
other words if i take uh you know uh
let's say
sarah
from the bible
right okay is sarah a woman
i i don't know the bible i don't know if
you've picked a weird example here well
i've picked a person that we don't know
existed right she may be a bible story
okay and therefore she may be a
depiction of a an adult human female but
um that doesn't mean
that she is a woman or if the story is
the story of sarah and the bible include
her having born children no no
the person in the bible i'm not picky
i'm picking sarah because she is a
female biblical name right who shows up
in the bible i believe in adulthood
now if the story depicts her entire life
she is born which probably it does
then the question is is sarah a woman
well then we could get into pedantic
stuff about the fact that the story
depicts her entire life anyway i'm not
arguing any of this is important because
we all understand exactly how you deal
with that ambiguity under normal
circumstances if you didn't have enemies
trying to cloud the the issue
so my only point is we are being dragged
into a world of sophistry somebody being
dragged into a world of sophistry has
the right to simply refuse to
participate and that right will be
abused many people will refuse to answer
questions that we pose about important
things by claiming that we are engaged
in sovereignty they will be wrong we
don't engage in sophistry but but the
point is
in a in a
world of landmines
this answer that actually okay if we're
going to get technical about what a
woman is then maybe we ought to bring in
a biologist strikes me as a reasonable
answer the question as much as i would
have preferred her to say adult even
female right i would prefer it but i
think you know
for example
i saw
uh eric tweeted eric your brother yes
tweeted a response to this and his point
was basically the one we are making this
is not a difficult question but he
included in his definition an exclusion
for intersex people which is absolutely
unnecessary
right i understand why you did it right
because there can be
ambiguities that blur boundaries you and
i would point to gametes as the defining
characteristic and nobody as far as we
know produces both gametes but even if
they did right that's not inconceivable
even if they did the point is these
uh
nuances do not change the fundamental
definition and i would point as you and
i taught repeatedly
when we were professors
the fact that
you cannot you know you've got a
mountain you've got a valley
at some point you've gone down the
mountain far enough to be in the valley
but there's no way to define what moment
that is does that mean mountains and
valleys are a social construct
no the river's in the valley it's not on
the mountaintop right so yeah you know
this this category though is a hell of a
lot less fuzzy than that i you know as i
have as i have said many many times many
places written written many essays on
this
you know
and as we as we have talked about as we
have written into the book and all um
you know gender is the software to the
hardware of sex sex is binary and yes
there are some
mistakes
in humans mistakes developmental
mistakes or genetic mistakes
but just like having zeros and ones in
your machine code
and then occasionally having missing
data or a question mark doesn't render
it non-binary sex is still binary gender
being the software of sex
um means you know basically the
behavioral expression of sex and are
there lots of you know art do i have a
lot of gender non-conformity um in you
know in part because i grew up with a
with a
dad who did a lot of stuff that i
thought was really cool and i wanted to
you know do the kinds of things he was
doing yeah
does that in any way call into question
whether or not i'm either a woman or a
female no
it makes me perhaps less feminine
which might be the gender description of
sex stereotypical
traits
but that's fine and that says absolutely
nothing about the underlying reality of
whether or not i am a female or male
woman or man but you are hearing me say
something that i am not saying my point
is those rare exceptions exist even if
they were common it wouldn't matter
it is not necessary to include an
exemption for them because the
definition works as is and my point
would be this is true for many things
for which we have definitions and are
not falling all over ourselves to make
these uh you know excursions into
sophistry so for example
you know the definition of electric
versus electronic
right this is a well understood
distinction right electronic involves
encoding information into the passage of
electricity uh through a circuit
right
but it is not hard to come up with
examples that you know one could argue
either way right
well i don't you picked an example that
i have
exactly zero history with i mean i've
i've built some electric circuits and
all but like you know you ask me
to define you know the distinction
electric and electronic and you have
only defined one of them even so you
only did half the job here i don't i
don't inherently know i have a sort of a
gist of a feeling for what the
difference is but i really think that
you'll be in part because that is a a
human-made system
reasonable people can disagree
more compellingly than and not only is
the system human made but the
categorizations are human made and the
fact is that female
exists as a category completely outside
of whether or not humans exist because
what the definition of woman is includes
the word human in it human woman doesn't
exist outside of human rights but it
exists outside and long before humans
ever had any idea of what it was and
frankly everyone knew it everyone people
weren't wandering around going like i
don't know male female i can't tell like
no one was doing that right this is not
confusing right this is sophistry but
you guys
electric electronic you know i feel like
this actually plays into their hands to
be talking about systems that are
specifically
at least in the case of electronic uh
anthropogenic but but i think again
you're hearing me say exactly the
opposite thing that i'm saying electric
versus electronic is a fair distinction
even though there are cases in which i
can poise something just on the cusp so
it could go either way like a
a telegraph key
right telegraph key just completes a
circuit over some long distance right
and it's used to send simple messages
right like we are under attack um so the
point is it's
uh by its design it's an electrical
circuit but it's playing the role of an
electronic circuit and you could argue
it either way
but the point is somebody who would pull
out that example and say well you are
falsely drawing a world of electric
versus electronic stuff right that
person would be engaged in sophistry the
point is there are tiny number of
examples yes we could you know
use a
we could agree
that a light bulb is electrical and not
electronic and then we could agree that
if i leave a particular light on that it
means something right so we can poise
things on that cusp without actually
challenging the fundamental nature of
definitions and the point is if you
apply the same standard the sophists are
using then we wouldn't be able to talk
about anything
true absolutely true i just think that
it is
further confusing and further adding
fuel to the insane fire that is somehow
erupting around all of us now to use by
comparison uh to
an ancient truth a tr so
there have been two sexes for something
up to something between one and two
billion years with a b
whether or not our lineage has been
sexually reproducing that entire time is
not totally clear we can't go back in
time with that amount of of clarity
probably probably so but we can know for
sure for at least 500 million years we
have been we have been reproducing
sexually
so to say ah but okay here's some
examples from a sphere um that is you
know electric exists outside of humans
but electronic doesn't uh and you know
we have created electronic systems to be
using two cat you know two definitions
one of which does exist outside of
humans one of which doesn't it just
muddies the waters i just i don't feel
that this is that this is a useful
comparison because it precisely
contributes to the idea that um you know
some of these people will call
themselves post-modernists some of them
will call they'll have lots of names for
themselves but you know the gender queer
you know lots of names
but the idea that you are what you say
you are that female is just a feeling
that humans can be uh sequential
hermaphrodites no no and no
it's just entirely false of course which
is why i'm saying
the definition is adult human female and
saying something like excluding intersex
people
the definition is adult human female is
unnecessary because adult human female
covers it no matter what even if you had
somebody who produced both kinds of
gametes that you and i would agree is a
special case yeah right and
i guess also and i actually um a while
back i i made a misstep on on on twitter
and said you know i've been using the
word
hermaphrodite
historically um
both accurately
when applied to other other organisms
because there are many other many other
organisms out there uh which are in
plants we would call it monicious having
both sexes on one body
so they can potentially self-fertilize
uh and you know famously like banana
slugs um are are hermaphroditic they
have both sets of um both male and
female parts
and they can act as male or act as
female in any particular sexual in fact
in fact they well you describe the case
uh of self-fertilizing as far as i know
slugs don't sell fertilized but they
mutually the male parts
fertilize the female parts of the other
and vice versa i do not know of any
examples and i would like to hear if
there are of
simultaneous hermaphrodites that are
animals that sell fertilize plants do it
but they do it as a last resort um self
fertilization will always be a last
resort
um but i don't think that any of the
simultaneous hermaphrodites and animals
sell fertilize um but they you know they
can they can be either female or male
they are both the same time and then
they can have basically the gender what
we call in non-humans the sex role of
female or male when they meet the thing
that is behaving the opposite way
um so that's simultaneous hermaphrodites
and
sometimes and then of course we have
sequential hermaphrodites things like
clownfish famously right like a lot of
reef fish and some some other organisms
some other animals um can be one sex of
one sex only and have all the behavioral
manifestations of that sex that is the
gender or the sex role and then they can
actually transition actually turn into
the other thing and there are lots of
amazing behavioral you know sexually
selected reasons for them to do that um
based on the mating system and the
ecology of where they are
but
humans
who are intersex
have been called in the literature
hermaphrodite somehow and they're not
and this is what i got um i i used the
term hermaphrodite uncarefully
and i got called to account for it and
and whoever it was who called me to
account this is a while back i was right
because hermaphrodite is a description
of a functional system hermaphrodite is
either again simultaneously or
sequentially having both sexes in a
single individual either at the same
time simultaneously or
over the course of a lifetime
sequentially whereas there are no
human hermaphrodites when intersex
happens it's not functional yep and so
and and you know and
even if so
even if there were there's still only
two sexes because hermaphrodite is a
both situation it's not a third
situation it's a there's a one there's a
two and oh there's a both one and two
but again right even if we had examples
of people who created both gametes and
they were both viable it wouldn't change
this definition it's robust to that and
so
my real point is that
language
is not built
to withstand an attack by sophists if we
are forced to engage sophists on their
territory we will not be able to govern
ourselves we will not be able to figure
out what we think is even taking place
and we're now seeing this right because
the point is there are certain rules
that obligate you right social rules
etiquette rules that obligate you to
engage things right and the truth must
be somewhere in the middle
but the point is it's not it doesn't
work and science also so you know uh at
the point uh that uh kenji uh kentucky
uh brown jackson says
that she's not a biologist katanji
katanji brown jackson says she's not a
biologist
she is actually deferring to something
that itself can't agree and it's not
because it's ambiguous it's because the
social pressure not to accept a simple
definition for women wait what do you
mean she's referring to she's deferring
to biologists saying this is a question
for biologists we know why she did that
she knows it's a minefield right well
but i mean so i have more to say about
what is actually going on with regard to
sex and organisms but um
i actually
i get that when you have been when you
have been
um called up by the president to
potentially be the next sitting justice
on scotus on the supreme court you are
gonna hedge and not answer and that's
what they do right like that that is
what happens
but in this case
the people who are presumably gunning
for her
like the you know the people who are
arguing that sex is a fiction in your
head and you can just transition
whenever you want to
those are the people on her team on what
we used to be we used to call our team
right those aren't the people who are
going to overturn the nomination no no
no i don't think that was the purpose of
this question i think the purpose of
this question she doesn't need she
as as i understand it one of the amazing
truths of the supreme court of the
united states is that once you are a
sitting justice
your team has no sway right your team
has no sway and her team
appointed her because your team would
appoint you and her team is the one
our
i don't know former team i don't even
know what team blue yeah
are exactly the people who are at least
pretending to be confused on this front
there's a tiny number of people who are
legitimately confused and i'm sorry for
them and i wish we could unconfuse you
but most of y'all are just pretending to
be confused and
she with her past with all of her wisdom
and education and i i trust that she has
actually been educated and she like she
she actually knows a lot about the world
knows damn well what a woman is of
course we all do and she is at no risk
of being canceled by team blue
that's not the point
okay
this is the same flaw that exists in our
system of elections for
members of the uh the executive and
legislative branch right where you get
an opportunity as somebody is trying to
get into the office to get concessions
from them right that you then hope will
bind them once they reach the office it
doesn't work at all right okay it's
[ __ ] but the point is we still labor
under
independent judicial branch independence
of course that's what it's supposed to
be yeah but the reason that we are
having this conversation is that she was
asked a question designed to
basically
get her to paint herself into one corner
or another right
i don't think in look if she was i guess
i would be very pleased to see people
paint themselves into the corner of
reality when it's so freaking
unambiguous of course you would and the
other side would be very glad to watch
anybody who paints themselves into the
obvious corner be uh emulated so that
but she won't be i'm not saying that i'm
saying this is the opportunity to create
a system of penalties and rewards
designed to constrain somebody this is
the worst possible place to try to
constrain somebody because the court is
designed not to allow it but it doesn't
mean that that's not the game that's
being played or that she is going to be
used as an example for others who are
not in the same context and so
um
that that may be it because i honestly
i'm just not buying
i'm not buying the argument otherwise
because it feels like usually there's
going to be a gotcha moment a series of
gotcha moments and it's going to be like
if you say the thing we know you're
thinking then we're not going to confirm
right and it's the opposite it's the
opposite situation here
right but my point is like she'd be
she'd be morgan i mean she i think she
will be confirmed but she'd be more
guaranteed to confirm if she could if
she just state the obvious
i don't know what would happen if she
stated the obvious
and like we're arguing about
the most
basic thing that toddlers recognize
right but this is my point it's the
sophistry right and the right answer to
sophistry is you know
come on senator you know what a woman is
we all do right that's the right answer
to the question no but then the
senator's is going to say well then
define it for me no thank you
then the point is um
there is no legitimate reason to ask for
such a definition of course i'm capable
of defining it as are you as is anyone
in this room but the entire idea that
anything hinges on the ability to define
obvious things right is evidence that
something with this process has gone
seriously awry and so my point is look
you and i are now dragged into a
conversation where we as biologists are
weighing in on what a woman is right
that's dumb now i don't think we have a
choice about it right because especially
in light of the fact that she invoked
biologists and i again i think this is
legitimate she too will have seen
biologists on twitter or youtube or
wherever claiming that this is ambiguous
and sex isn't the simple thing we once
thought it was and all of the stuff that
we have seen right that's because like
language science is not robust to
sophistry
it's not robust to uh pressure campaigns
designed to unmake reality for political
reasons which is why we are having this
fight in the first place
and so the simple answer is yeah this is
really as simple as you thought it was
yes there are interesting things that
happen in other creatures yes there are
interesting errors that happen in human
development none of it changes the
basics here at all anybody who says that
it does change the basics is motivated
by something else which may well be fear
it may be fear of what happens if they
say the obvious and so they may be
doing exactly the wrong thing and they
may be uh
you know
reneging on their agreement with the
rest of us and pretending that something
is complicated that isn't but the trick
is how do we get back to a place
where we aren't compelled to engage
sophists
and
we
do not
empower people to claim anything they
don't want to answer is sophistry in
other words what we need is a good faith
environment in which only sophistry is
dismissed on this basis but sophistry is
reliably dismissed so that we don't get
dragged into taking apart civilization
because somebody's got a bunch of gotcha
questions that we're going to struggle
to answer simply
you have an answer
uh how do we get back to that place well
i think we need to recognize this and
then i want to talk about tortoises then
it's happening well before you get to
tortoises i want to point out but no
answer my question first you said how do
we get back how you asked the question
how do we get back to a place where i
guess we do not we are not obligated to
respond to sophists because they are at
risk of burning down civilization uh
obviously it's a big question but do you
have uh the beginning of an answer yeah
i got the beginning of an answer the
beginning of an answer is this is a
matter of a social contract where those
of us who are dependent on civilization
have to recognize that above all else
this must hold that if we empower
sophists that sophistry does not have to
be answered in order to proceed
right
and the point is that okay but that's
gameable ah that's a that's that's
sophistry i don't have to address that
what you need is let's say democrats and
republicans to agree that the republic
will fail if sophists are allowed to
steer the conversation and in fact every
conversation which they are now doing
right and so the basic point is we may
not be able to agree on anything else
but we should agree on this principle
right that sophistry uh does not require
an answer and that the abuse of the
claim that something is sophistry is a
problem and there's got to be some no
man's lands in the details in terms of
operationalization though no it's not
because the point is we all know what a
woman is and anybody who can't say that
they do at this moment in history has
failed on the agreement and anybody who
says we all know what a woman is there
may be some
nuances that i'm not schooled enough to
understand but nonetheless okay but we
don't we can't all provide definitions
of electronic versus electric no that's
a case where specialists face this issue
so there's a lot of space in between
there where some people will say you're
just engaging in software and other
people saying like oh i don't really
legitimately just i'm not paying
attention to that right so then we need
an agreement on that which is to say
that sophistry does not require an
answer and there's some gray area where
we can't tell quite whether something is
sophistry and those things probably do
require an answer we need to err in the
direction of answering but there's a
point at which you've gone far enough
that you have indicted yourself and and
i want to give an example of this okay
a twitter thread showed up friend of
ours pointed uh
i think you probably saw it
but pointed us to it on a shared chat
zach do you want to put up the uh
what is her
name it's uh sheree becker
um sheree becker
somebody i've never heard of before she
is apparently a phd
uh i think she's a professor in bath
england can you even begin it
um
generated a thread this week that i want
to be careful with it okay because
oh i have seen this the point some
people could not see it because they are
listening they are listening all right i
will describe it she has a 20-tweet
thread in which she
lays out the argument that women's
sports
were not generated to protect women from
male competition but exactly the
opposite that in fact men did not want
competition from women and women's
sports were invented to protect
men that women had started encroaching
on women on men's sports and they of
course were just kicking ass and taking
names because that's what you do when
you're a superhero
and then the men were like
patriarchy let's make women's sports so
the women can't continue to beat us
right that's the argument that's the
argument but this is a 22 impressive
well i i want to be careful and not do
that thing because it is quite clear
that uh sorry it's
becker yeah
that sheree becker is no dummy
and this thread
is actually really impressive right if
you set somebody the job here is a wrong
argument i want you to lay out the best
case you can for this wrong argument you
would come up with something like she's
come up with here right it's not without
evidence she's got examples
of places that where she may even be
right right where you know things like
skeet shooting right the advantages that
males have athletically may not have any
implication in skeet shooting or they
may i don't really know look and i've
written about in fact i was interviewed
by the bbc a couple years ago about the
advantages that women may have in
extreme long distance running like
50 mile and longer races
uh and you know i mean it may not be an
advantage it may be an extremely solid
small sample size with one or two
extraordinary female athletes but there
also could be reasons that um
extraordinary endurance extraordinary
physical endurance
like women have to endure in childbirth
uh could allow for greater capacity in
some in some athletics right and there's
even a way in which we can take the
logic that underlies how men and women
became different and we should probably
go into that logic and it might select
for exactly that right absolutely um and
you know so you should expect that there
will be places where physically
if not by burst speed or strength
um that women will will do better at
some tasks of course right yeah so
in any case my point is
the temptation when looking like a
thread like this is
come on and that's right in one way but
oh come on you're a dummy and that's
dumb isn't right the argument is
actually really well architected and
that's the problem with sophistry so
this that's that's your point here is
that that is whether or not dr becker
knows that that's what she's doing she
is engaging in extraordinarily high
level sovereignty extraordinarily high
level and it's really important that you
have a right not to respond to this now
on twitter you can just not respond but
the point is her argument is um
one that either
i mean the fact is i looked at this
thing and i was expecting it to be
nonsense
right and i can tell where the bodies
are buried in her argument she's got
three examples of places where
women actually were threatening to men
in some way one of them being skeed
shooting i've forgotten
another one which was like skeet
shooting where
physical
strength
was irrelevant
and then one of them had to do
with a threat in football where women
obviously are not capable of competing
with men in football but they were
competing for attention i think men were
at war and women started playing
football
and
so you know who knows what the truth of
this example is but it's obviously not a
case where uh female athletic prowess
was a threat to men it's obviously just
sort of
loosely in the same neighborhood right
and then she uses
the endurance and certainly i'm not like
i did not i don't know the examples
you're talking about except by virtue of
you saying them just now but you know if
just i mean this sounds like a
caricature but men are at war so women
start their own football league and they
start playing football that
it's a little questionable i feel like
women would start a different sports
league but okay fine um
yeah the men come back like okay ladies
you can have yours and we're gonna have
ours like of course they would would
that sound paternalistic to many people
sure but is it actually better for
everyone uh-huh yeah and even even if
it's not the point is none of these are
a demonstration for the things she
appears to be
uh advancing as an argument which is
that actually the difference in physical
prowess isn't all that it's cracked up
to be and the point is you know men were
threatened and so they created women's
sports to keep them out of their leagues
which is not true right right but but
but the overarching point is look
sophists are not inherently dumb in fact
years ago i was prone to look up who the
sophists were
because
this is obvious you mean the actual the
greeks the greeks offices yeah and the
sophists were tutors
right and in some sense i don't know the
true story but it's sort you know look
in in debate
right in like high school and college
debate which you did which i did the
whole point is
we are going to hand you a position it's
like being a lawyer right somebody walks
through your door and whether their side
of the argument is the one that you
would naturally
fall to you're gonna advocate it so
right um so the point is you don't know
you know going into a round you flip a
coin to see who's affirmative and who's
negative and the point is you deploy all
your arguments and you know you may know
where the bodies are buried you know how
you are it's about argument and evidence
not about underlying reality right so
they may have been very good tutors i
don't know right but the point is a they
were hired guns they were hired to teach
and the sophistry was about nonsense
arguments that were high quality right
and so anyway
civilization cannot be allowed to fall
because of sophistry and i think the
deepest point which you and i have about
male and female which is really hard
without the benefit of you know a
classroom and people returning week
after week to make
is that this has nothing to do with
people
right right well this is i mean
as i mentioned however you know 20
minutes ago or so
like
some of the people who call themselves
post-modernists make this error and i
don't actually know to what degree it's
just an obvious bastardization of some
of the core interesting principles in
post-modernism of which there are a few
uh but the
you see these arguments that basically
like until there was a word for a thing
the thing did not exist
and i mean i've seen i've seen that
construction a few places by and by
people who are being serious who really
and you know it's
if this if that isn't a religious
position i don't know what is
you know like
you really think it took human naming of
the thing to make the thing exist
well then
that's actually the point at which i'm
not sure how to proceed in talking to
you because you do not appear to believe
in an underlying objective reality
will do we know what that underlying
objective reality is in the case of male
and female yes we do but in the case of
overall
no
is science the best method we have for
getting a better
and ever better approximation of the
truth of the reality yes it is do we
have missteps yes we do do we certainly
believe some things now which will turn
out to not be true yes we yes we do but
is there an objective reality which we
can aspire to understand yes or no
this is maybe the only question that you
could ask me or that that i could ask a
person if they say no
like i think i'm out then i just don't
know what to do with you if you if you
really don't think there's an objective
reality what what is the basis of any of
the conversation right there's nothing
there's nothing to be done yeah and the
problem is it's an argument that can be
deployed
as sophistry too of course yes
and it is
but
let's briefly go through the the deep
question right of what it means
what male and female actually means at
the level before you get to human beings
to interpret it right because i really
think that this is the thing that will
cause people's the light bulb to go on
over people's heads yeah so oh go ahead
um well maybe that can
let me just do a little little bit um
of related stuff first before you
because i think what you're talking
about is the the ultimate the most
interesting layer but just
um
you know what
what makes you female is having these um
large sessile gametes and what makes you
male is having these small zippy gametes
um but very often when humans especially
modern humans talk about it they talk
about being xx or xy right they talk
about the chromosomes
and
in humans as
the vast majority of mammals there being
a few very weird exceptions at the base
of the mammal tree the monotremes the
echidnas and the duckbill platypus which
have like cot what is it like 10 or 12
pairs of sex chromosomes it's crazy i
thought it was five but anyways maybe
it's five and they got ten in pairs i
like i i don't actually remember um and
it's very it's variable between the
three or five species depending on how
many echidnas you think there are
anyway um
the marsupials um and the placental
mammals the two other major groups of
mammals um
which are basically every mammal that
you can think of that's not an echidna
or a duckbill platypus not basically
that is everything
have
what's called genetic sex determination
which means that we have
all of us
a pair of chromosomes and if a pair of
sex chromosomes is opposed to all the
other autosomes that we have and it's
variable between species like um you
know humans have
23 pairs of chromosomes and that 23rd
one is the sex chromosomes chimps
and i think bonobos um who are together
our closest living relatives have
is it 24 and their diploid number is 48
or is it 22 i think it's different than
that
but i don't remember which way it is
yeah i think it's one more i think i
think so too but i don't i don't totally
remember so you know and and there's
going to be i'm sure there's other
mammals out there whose haploid number
who's you know
how many how many pairs of chromosomes
do you have is 23 like ours um and um
they aren't going to be as closely
related to us
um as the chimps and bonobos
and so in in us
in chimps in girards in kangaroos in
wombats in sperm whales even female
sperm whales um there is a pair
of sex chromosomes and if you have two
x's
then you're female
and if you have an x and a y then you're
male but it's not that um
that is what underlyingly makes you
female it's that's what determines your
sex okay so in mammals we have xx
determines that you will become female
absent other weird developmental things
that might happen and if your xy
that that the position at that last set
of chromosomes determines what sex you
are there are other species there are
other clades that have genetic sex
determination
birds famously but in birds it's the
opposite and so we use we use different
letters to use w's and z's but whereas
in mammals females are the homogeneic
sex meaning we have two two x's as
opposed to the heterogametic sex for
males and x and y in birds uh females
are heterocommedic and they have a y and
a z and uh males are homogeneic and they
don't i don't never remember if it's two
w's or two z is whatever
um and that actually has um some
interesting implications for how their
ecology plays out but they still have
genetic sex determination
whereas and we're just sticking to
vertebrates here there's lots of species
of vertebrates that don't have genetic
sex determination at all that don't
appear to have anything in their
chromosomes that says aha got it i'm
going to set you down the path to being
male or female they have some form of
environmental sex determination so um
in
many oviparous species for instance that
is um egg-laying species as opposed to
viviporous species like us who give live
birth
you have the temperature of the egg at a
critical moment in development that
determines what sex you will be which
means at the point that that egg is laid
it is still open you still could become
male or female but any individual that
kind of doesn't become one or the other
isn't viable is an evolutionary dead end
and so just a few examples in tortoises
males develop
males develop from eggs that were in
that critical period at low temperatures
and females at higher temperatures
in many lizards and alligators it's the
opposite females develop at the lower
temperatures and males at the higher
temperatures and in crocodiles and
snapping turtles both cool and warm
temperatures during that critical period
during egg development um turn into
females whereas it's the intermediate
temperatures that produce males so
there's all sorts of ways to determine
whether or not you some developing
embryo are going to become male or
female and in species with environmental
sex determination
they're you know things like if you live
in a place that is warming you might
suddenly have a population crash because
now you've got all females are all males
this is going to be a problem
whereas for organisms like mammals and
birds with genetic sex determination and
a few other and several other species as
well
the
the temperature at which we are
incubated doesn't seem to matter of
course with mammals we've endotherms and
we have viviparity
and so we've got this constant internal
um gestational environment but for for
birds who do lay eggs
yes mama and depending on species papa
birds sit on the eggs and keep them warm
but that keeping them warm doesn't
change what sex they are because that's
already on board in their genetics so
all of these things are true
and none of it changes the underlying
thing which is that whether or not you
got there because you developed cool you
developed hot you had an xx you had a zw
if
as an adult
you are capable of producing large
sessile gametes you are female
and if as an adult you are capable of
producing small zippy gametes you are
male and that cannot be changed
all right
now i want to add the thing that i think
is most surprising on top of all of that
really shocking stuff that you just laid
out okay
imagine that you walk into a forest
right imagine that you exist
five thousand years ago before we
understood any of this right
or imagine you landed on this planet
from somewhere else okay
it sounds like and you
walk into a forest and you find animals
of some type what we would call a
species
and some of these animals are behaving
in a way
that is finicky about who to have sex
with
and some other animals are enthusiastic
to have sex with
whichever
ones will have them
right
and you said okay i know nothing about
these creatures of how they work
but i'll bet you those ones that are
finicky
have big gametes and i bet you that the
ones that are
uh
hot to trot
irrespective of the qualities of the
other
have
small motile gametes
you'll almost always be right right
and the reason for this is that
let's walk back a little bit so
presumably the initial condition is when
gametes so you have
uh asexual creatures that don't make
gametes at all there's an advantage to
fusing two half genomes together right
we can debate about what that is and
it's actually not entirely certain it's
a little harder to come up with a robust
argument for why the
genetic variation that comes from sex
reproduction is a good thing
we'll go into that some other day
but for the moment let's just say that
there's a reason that
uh natural selection
invents sexual reproduction repeatedly
it's not for all creatures but for many
creatures it appears to be essential
um
so selection invents this thing
presumably when it first does you get
two gametes that are the same size
right um we would call that isogamous
gametes now isogamus gametes is a stable
equilibrium it's an unstable equilibrium
which means that you can't tell which
way it's going to go but it can't stay
where it is because as soon as one
type of creature starts
cheaping out on how much it invests in
these gametes the other one can't keep
out in response it actually has to over
invest and so what you see
the additional problem well two
additional problems
are the reason for one of the sets of
gametes to be large is because you can't
make a baby just with
dna right right you need the cytoplasmic
structure the cellular machinery and
someone's got to bring that and if you
both bring it if both male and female
bring it they're going to argue
actually right they're going to argue
about who's cellular machinery to use
maybe and and in part because there is
mitochondrial dna right there's actual
genetic material in some of the
cytoplasm and then also if you're both
kind of move kind of middling size and
kind of both have some cytoplasm then
when you get together you might argue
about who's mitochondria to use
um you're also both kind of slow and
lumpy and you're going to have a harder
time finding one another
so exactly as you say there's an
unstable
there's an unstable equilibrium and so
an unstable equilibrium is kind of an uh
hard concept to grasp because um
let's think about it this way if you did
a computer model of what happens if you
put a marble a perfect marble on
in exactly in the center balanced on the
head of a perfect pin
right
the computer will tell you that the
marble doesn't do anything it doesn't
fall off why because it doesn't know
which way to fall off it's equally
likely to fall off in all ways which
holds it right there now in our
experience this never happens because
there are no perfect marbles there are
no perfect pins and there is no
perfectly stable environment where you
won't have the tiniest bit of wind or
the tiniest shaking of the earth that
will cause it to be slightly more this
way than that way and once it's slightly
more this way than that way then it goes
that direction so the point is the
equilibrium is a technical fact can i
have zach show this while you're talking
so this is a figure from
dalian wilson's
book from the 1980s uh
called the evolution of sex and behavior
i believe and this is
uh my computer is playing funny games um
and it's gonna be it's gonna be small
for you guys but um
it it describes the both the unstable
and the stable equilibrium the unstable
equilibrium of isogamy in which gametes
are the same size and both have
arguments about about mitochondrial dna
and have a hard time finding one another
and the anisogamy the unequal sized
and
sort of structured gametes that results
that is a stable equilibrium all right
so
equal size gametes is the initial
starting condition it immediately breaks
apart in favor of a small motile and a
large sessile gamete
but the crazy part is once that happens
and it doesn't matter how many times
this process happens where selection
favors sexual reproduction produces
equal size gametes and then the unstable
equilibrium breaks apart and creates one
uh
subtype that makes large gametes and one
subtype that makes small games every
time that happens
maleness and femaleness follow
right that is to say the characteristics
that cause the you know the behaviors of
these creatures follow because once
you're stuck with one of these kind of
gametes certain things make sense from
the point of view of selection and other
things don't make sense and so
well i guess i'd like for you to be
i
i think i want you to correct your
language there a little bit
the state of having a small zippy gamete
is the state of being male the state of
having a large sessile gamut is the
state of being female the
software that follows the behavior for
animals the behavioral manifestation the
choosiness the displayiness the you know
and all of these things that follow
are
for lack of better terms perhaps the
typically feminine the typically
masculine it's not the femaleness of the
maleness the females and the maleness
exist and they do not change based on
how it is that those organisms will
later behave let's put it this way i
agree with your correction but it's not
even software right because we see it in
plants where there is no software right
it's the behavior and now this is this
you're the one who wants to call it
software i'm always the one calling it
behavior and you say software is the
more inclusive term that includes plants
because i wouldn't say that plants have
a gender so that we're where we usually
get into this is what's the definition
of gender and i say it's the software of
sex right
in a plant and you know the point i love
to make is that even in a plant that is
a a hermaphrodite that has both
male and female right that produces both
actually i don't think there are
sequential hermaphrodites in plants are
there uh kind of
at least kind of because there are
plants that avoid self-fertilization by
the gametes maturing so it's oh
different it's but it's sort of
short-term skills than the way animals
do it but it's a very short time scaling
yeah like per flower yeah yeah um but
anyway the point is even in a flower
that has both male and female parts
right the female parts are reluctant
about sex and they put the male parts
through a test right a long corolla tube
that the pollen grains have to grow down
in order to reach the eggs whereas the
pollen grains are totally hot to trot
and they are not discriminating right so
in a plant that is wind dispersed it'll
produce lots of pond it lands anywhere
tries to fertilize whatever it lands on
the male
uh plant parts will
hire insects to carry their you know
to carry the the pollen grains out to to
female plants it's always male insects
because they're also the ones who are
easily fooled because they're so eager
for sex well actually it's not because
it's bees yeah and you're talking about
the the orchid like hawk mods and such
yeah yeah but anyway the point is the
enthusiasm
for sex with strangers
tracks the gamete size even though
presumably this has nothing to do with
shared ancestry between animals and
plants because i don't even think the
common ancestor of these two things had
sexual reproduction
no no they they
they probably they did um so sex evolves
um boy i'm gonna have to i'd have to go
back and it's gonna be some yeast like
colonial
something or other right
um
well i mean it involves a few six of
those a few times yeah but in the
lineage that you know when i say
definitely back 500 million years we can
track that and maybe up to two billion
years there's you know there's a lot
that happens in that one to two billion
years space and i'm not sure
how precise we can be about exactly when
that was and therefore when uh in the
branching between plants and animals
that was i i'm actually not sure okay
but the overarching point on which i
know we agree is that
it is the constraints of the mode of
reproduction that cause the behavior to
become what it is which then in
creatures like us becomes a software
program that uh is gender but but the
point is the behavior precedes there
being any software involved at all it's
just a set of strategies that make sense
if you are the small gaming producing
type versus a set of strategies that
make sense if you are the large gamete
producing type which means that male and
female have a meaning in the universe
beyond something beyond the gametes it's
the strategy that follows from the
gametes right this couldn't have less to
do with people right and people are in a
sense interesting because in the sense
the software
is partially sexual reversed in us
right a both males and females are
choosy right that exists in other
creatures but we are asymmetrically
choosy we choose for different things
which is pretty interesting
um and the ornaments both display yeah
yeah the ornamented sex is female right
typically if you find a displaying bird
or spider or something like this that's
the male right and so
the it's not that these things don't get
changed around but the basic logic of
choosiness isn't uh
inverted
and even as the software changes and the
rules change and even if they didn't
we're just talking about averages and
there's plenty of masculine acting women
and feminine acting men it does not
change the underlying sex that they are
it does not it does not now the last
point i
want to would make
oikos a little bit just a little bit
more on this topic all right
the the last point that i wanted to make
is
that the basic underlying logic of
basically males with their small gametes
are hot to trot because they're
investing
less in offspring gets changed
especially in something it gets changed
in any creature where there is teaming
up on raising offspring because
because the point is the logic is uh
um unmade to the extent that males are
cheating on investment by producing
small gametes that contain very little
as soon as males are forced to invest
then they
view the world in a way that is more
symmetrical to the way females naturally
see it you would get more symmetry in
those species but you would also have
species with sexual reversal
where you have
something about the ecological
conditions has created a system in which
males are investing more than females so
something like polyandrous birds like
chicanas
or seaheas
seaheas which is our family term for
seahorses
where males are they do produce the
smaller gametes hence they're being
males but they engage in the pregnancy
they and they really i mean i actually
wrote a piece on my substance about this
um and i i had not i had not known
to what degree we understood the level
of
um
analogy to uh to mammalian pregnancy
that male seahorses have i mean the the
the cardiovascular and i believe
neurological but certainly
cardiovascular integration of the fetus
um with the father's body is
extraordinary in sea horses they really
yeah it's it's they are actually
pregnant and obviously you know the egg
didn't come from them so they brought
this in
but then it embeds in a way that is
extraordinarily like pregnancy all right
so yeah the the way
you'll understand the point of this but
they're still males if this makes sense
to you there are things about the
interaction between the baby sea horses
and their
father who is male because of the
gametes that he produces that are beyond
what you will understand that are beyond
what we understand that are likely
beyond what we will ever scientifically
understand about the system
however
the
underlying logic of the system is
relatively easy to understand which is
if you're gonna invest you're gonna be
choosy right yes that's the driving
force and the point is it takes no
complexity to see it right yeah and just
just think that through just think like
okay
if i'm going to invest
am i going to take everything that comes
at me in any context at all like no if
you're going to invest you're going to
be choosy right there it is and so to
the extent that you have sophists
arguing that um you know it's the
patriarchy that uh caused
women to be
reluctant about casual sex just think it
through for yourself no freaking way
right the fact is if having sex is going
to stick you with a
an offspring that you're going to carry
with you for nine months give birth to
and then have to take care of very
intensively for you know six seven eight
years and then you know to some extent
until it's 15 16 17 years of age right
you don't want to produce such a thing
willy-nilly and you don't want to
produce it without an agreement
uh to co-parent if such an agreement is
a possibility so hence females will be
coy about sex right that has nothing to
do with the patriarchy right in fact the
patriarchy protects women because
you know both men and women have an
interest in the women in their group
being protected from men who would
inseminate them and run off
there's plenty of places where the
patriarchy which is not a word i tend to
use
does not protect women at all or very
well and one of one of those places is
another boy i heard from um
uh is with what's happening now with
regard to our apparent inability to
understand what women are which is thus
allowing
men to claim they're women and to beat
women in sports which is a much you know
it's it's it's both important and not
nearly as important as the fact that
once you have that then you start
letting men into women's prisons and uh
and you know and everywhere else like
all the dominoes fall so wait wait wait
let's be clear about that okay the
problem here so first of all i'm not a
believer in the patriarchy i believe
that there is a patriarchal force but
the patriarchy is a made-up fiction that
cannot exist because it doesn't make
sense for um
male to
gang up on female given that the
majority in fact the huge majority of
everybody's genome doesn't know in the
next round whether it's going to be male
or female but i heard
i heard that the reason
get into it yeah
there's this there's this crazy you know
this but for our audience there's this
insane and apparently taken seriously in
some circles uh
theory over in i don't even know what
fill-in-the-blank studies um that argues
that the reason that humans are sexually
dimorphic sexually seized dimorphic
which is to say men are on average
bigger than women
we all know this um
it's because historically men were
constantly stealing food from women and
thus women were starving which caused
them to be smaller and the smaller women
did a better job of surviving because i
didn't need as much but that's only
because the men were always stealing
food from them
right
so so actually i don't say this very
often but i can't even right but
but the point is this is like somebody
starts with the human case and they've
never thought about the other cases in
nature because there's dimorphism of
both directions right
you know in eagles the female is bigger
yeah raptors tend to have female and and
uh many many herps actually many of the
many amphibians and reptiles uh females
are larger in part because they tend to
be oviparous and they're carrying the
eggs on their body and they need a
bigger structure in general to to do
that and uh dick alexander my advisor
made a compelling case that animals that
compete in three dimensions rather than
two
males are selected for agility rather
than uh force that's cool but um but
let's take the the basic underlying
logic of dimorphism
in monogamous species
what you tend to get are individuals of
the same size right that's the
basic case
as
males
have the potential to have more mates
there is a priority put on their being
able to displace each other which then
causes them to be distorted to be pushed
off the ecologically optimum size for
whatever the creature in question is
towards larger size they accept a cost
in order to be able to displace each
other for sex which frankly also has
this consequence of making them fragile
right so males are bigger in many
species they are stronger and they are
shorter lived and only part of that is
because they're asking people to hold
their beer and then doing stupid [ __ ]
that gets them killed but the but to
hold my beer while i do this stupid [ __ ]
that might get me killed is also
sexually selected right exactly it is
sexually selective so you i thought you
were i would i would have included
a fourth word in there you said bigger
stronger
uh shorter lived bigger stronger
in general in non-sexual reverse species
um the more
this will be more true the more
poliginous the species
stronger
bigger stronger showier showier showier
and showier can mean the tail
or the dance or the song
or the car or you know any number of
things well and in humans you have two
kinds of showier right you've got
show-offs who tend to be male and you've
got females who are
physically augmented in a way that
advertises the presence of resources of
the kind that are necessary for a woman
to be fertile and produce offspring
and you know these things are
monitored by
uh
by the two sexes right um but anyway the
again the overarching message is this is
the very special human case of something
so impossibly long-standing and so
um central that every time selection
produces the two different sized gametes
it produces
variations on the same pattern it's
nothing to do with people right and so
the idea that a you know a generation of
people is going to forget
um the obvious and start engaging in
sophistry and gacha-ism
right it's like well you know so
historians um like to complain and i
think correctly um that
history isn't being taught that we don't
know our history that lots of people
don't know the relevant things from
history and so of course we will end up
making the same errors over and over
again and one of the things that is true
of evolution at least you know the the
branch to which we have referred here
but it's not the branch that we are
mostly in so macroevolution as opposed
to microevolution
um is that it is an historical science
um and it uses many of the same um
it has to use the same kind of inference
as history does and you know history
because that is defined as sort of
post-literate and therefore in general
there will be texts you're still using
what people thought about or claim to
think about it at the time but in
historical science which is to say
macroevolution or geology also has to
use inference has to use indirect
mechanisms methods by which to assess
what actually happened
yeah uh it has it's left with no choice
because um the uh
well you can't experiment on the time
machine large scale patterns
all right no but with regard to macro
evolution because they're because we
don't have a time machine we just can't
go back and know that's what i mean you
can't you can't run the experiment right
you can you can create uh you know
speciation events in
very
rapidly accelerated critters but you
can't figure out you know
how how birds evolve that way you have
to go back to fossils in which a lot of
the evidence has been erased by by time
yep
all right um
maybe we're there
i wanted to um
so oh wow it's two so we may just not do
any of the other stuff that we were
gonna do this week but
but
um i did want to and so i went i just i
went looked at dictionaries and i did
want to say that i also looked at this a
dictionary of ecology evolution
systematics which is a book i used to
assign to my upper division science
students
i think that the second edition which is
what this is which was published the
second edition was published in 1998
reprinted in 2003 that's the version i
have here
at least while i was still teaching
they had stopped at the second edition
and it wasn't being republished much
but i went and i decided to look up
the relevant terms here and of course
woman isn't in here because this is a
dictionary of ecology evolution of
systematic systematics basically being
macroevolution the the deep history
um
and it's it's a fabulous resource it
really is uh female though i looked up
female
and uh
to my surprise not at all found
the egg producing form of a bisexual or
dioecious organism
compared to male
okay
so that's all exactly as we have already
described um but i thought
oh right dioecious well diocese warrants
a
definition and while i assumed that both
of us could provide one off the top top
of our heads
i looked it up in here as well
and it says used of plants or plant
species having male and female
reproductive organs on different
individuals unisexual
dioecious um
compared to
monicious or triesious
and
right right and so that's where i went
oh
what well i looked up triaesius and um
let's see did i did i tag it i did try
issues so let's just say um that
diesel dioecious is
is what we call hermaphroditism in um no
no diocese is uh monicius is what we
call hermaphroditism in animals so we
just because botanists and zoologists i
don't know don't get along or just you
know generated words separately
we have we very often have different
words for the same things um so what you
would call a uh hermaphroditic species
and an animal you would call a monicious
species which means one house one house
exactly and so with regard to triesis i
went
what
what are they talking about used of a
plant and this actually this this
connects perfectly to what you said
about um sophistry and making an
exception for intersex
used of a plant species having male
female
and hermaphrodite flowers on different
individuals
so this is a case in which there are
three types of individuals and we know
of no cases i know of no cases in which
animal species do this yeah but a
species in which there are male
individuals there are female individuals
and there are simultaneously
hermaphroditic individuals triesis three
houses again um and so i actually want
to just do a little diversion into isis
and oikos and everything
but
no there's not some third category the
third category here the third type of
individual is
you know you have a you have b or you
have a and b
it's not c it's not a third thing it's
not an 87th gender right like it's it's
it's a and b it's not it's not a totally
new thing um so that sent me just
because i went here and i thought it was
kind of fun
um
into so isis
which is the same route as the echo
actually in ecology and economics comes
from the greek for oikos
the greek meaning household which is
oikos and indeed there's an ecological
journal called oikos
um and it has a lot of different
meanings actually in greek and it turns
out to be a very important word
but in looking up what um what it really
means i found this paper leshem 2016
published in 2016 in the journal of
economic perspectives
uh the paper is called retrospectives
what do the ancient greeks mean by
okinomia which i guess is the root for
um economics and i just wanted um
to
wait wrong
to share one sentence from this this is
the journal of economic perspectives
published in 2016.
um deep in the article he says
the earliest appearance the root word
for okonomiya is found in a poem by
facilities in the sixth century before
the common era that reflects the
misogynic he says
of texts from this age the poet
classifies women by comparing them to
different kinds of animals and advises
friends advises his friends to marry a
bee-like wife because she is quote a
good economist who knows how to work
economists usually translate as stuart
so that was um entertaining for me to
discover
um and it
it reflects
part of why i think some smart people
are legitimately confused right that
there is of course a long history of
sexism and misogyny in all of the
important intellectual traditions 100 we
know this anyone who claims not is is
lying to themselves or to you right and
so we see that here that doesn't mean
just as you have already said that there
is some you know
patriarchy that is
stealing food from women or you know you
know whatever whatever it is that they
are that they are claiming
but that there are patriarchal
structures in place
that have in part um sort of handed the
domain of the domestic to the females
and handed the public-facing outward
domain to men and that of course leaves
men with power and resources
to control is is of course true um but
that doesn't change the underlying truth
of what male and female are and
um
so let me just uh
yeah follow on from there yes
this is one of the reasons people
who watch this channel or listen to it
regularly will have heard me invoke
lineage a million times
this is one of the reasons that it is so
essential that we begin to think
evolutionarily in terms of lineage right
because as long as the problem is that
the individual is more tractable right
it is easier to comprehend right what is
the lineage right well a lineage is
actually a fractal right you're a part
of many lineages simultaneously so it's
a little bit hard to wrap your mind
around it and what level is operative in
any given interaction
but until you do
you can start thinking that there is a
patriarchy and that that patriarchy is
inflicting things on
women right and the point is
no that wouldn't really make any sense
in a lineage context right the lineage
may
uh divide things very unfairly in fact
pregnancy itself
is very unfair right tell me about it
yeah right well this is a perfect
opportunity for me to mansplain stuff
yeah right tell me about how rotten
pregnancy can be well but that's just
the thing is it's for you because you
had to live with me oh my god no this is
exactly this is exactly it is the fact
is it is unfairly divided but it is
unfairly divided by biology not by
uh men being insensitive to women right
it's
non-equally divided
let's just
you know
there are lots of i mean look warfare
that's dudes that's also unfairly
defined it's unfairly divided um but the
point is these things have been divided
up
because it got our lineage into the
future right now as you and i make the
point in our book
we are up
for a renegotiation of a lot of these
things right you can't renegotiate
pregnancy we probably should not
renegotiate war for the most part but
maybe think about how
you know that's a short-term
strategy that's going to make it
impossible to live on this planet but
nonetheless the point is
we are here we can work together to
reduce war right
but you know the actual war part biology
and getting getting into the future is
not easy we got here we got here with a
lot of stuff unevenly divided in lots of
different ways
right and more evenly dividing that
which can be more evenly dividing
divided is a good idea
but pretending that this is about
somebody being mean
right is preposterous that's just not
how lineage works and
um anyway you know look
at some point you know we've seen the
sophists now argue that the reason that
women's sports were invented was not to
protect women from male competition but
exactly the reverse right
how far can we really be from an
argument that women's prisons were
invented to protect male prisoners from
being assaulted by women who had
committed crimes yeah
right female criminals can be rough
they can and so you know yes men
invented these uh women's prisons to
protect uh male prisoners right um that
argument's coming at some point
presumably and we have an obligation to
learn how to stop being so damn
responsive as if the fact that an
argument is difficult to field means
that it's valid right a lot of these
arguments just aren't valid and are
obviously not valid even if you can't
put your finger uh on the reason why in
the moment and i guess the last time
that doesn't make you wrong right so i
would i would point out that there's a
trick that uh people will use in
argument sometimes which is if you say
something
they will ask you to define a word
in what you've said
right
you will find that if you give yourself
the assignment of defining the important
words and the arguments you make it's
very difficult right we constantly use
words that we cannot define and that is
not an indication that we are fakers it
is an indication of the way the meaning
of words is held it's not held in the
conscious mind in a place that you can
immediately bring up the you know the
the meaning of any of the things that
you're saying and so um you know the
sophists can use this against you until
you realize that your inability to
define a word is not an indication that
you don't know what it means right um
and i guess you know
let's stop being backed into a corner by
this stuff excellent
all right uh
we'll get to a bunch of other stuff next
week right yes we will awesome uh we are
going to take a break
we thank you for having been here uh
with us this however long it's been and
if you are interested in more consider
sticking around for the q a uh you can
ask questions at
www.darkhorsesubmissions.com
and if you want a
forum
where we do a q a that's live and we can
actually engage with the people in the
chat that's happening on sunday march
27th we do it at the last sunday of
every month 11am pacific and then we
leave it up for those of you who miss it
and want to see which you can get to at
my patreon
so
if you have logistical questions about
anything you can email
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
uh if you liked this conversation um you
know much more than a lot of the stuff
we've ended up talking about up late but
this conversation fits exactly with our
book hunter gatherers guide the 21st
century we've got two chapters
um one on sex and gender another on
relationship and parenthood another on
childhood but that are all exactly in
the domain of what we've been talking
about today
and uh and no sophistry no
sophistry at all
until we see you next
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside
[Music]